[MUSIC PLAYING]
WESLEY CHUN:
Greetings, developers,
and welcome to
Serverless Migration
Station, a miniseries that's
part of Serverless Expeditions.
I'm Wesley, your conductor
on these short trips.
Joining me is
Martin, who will help
me help you navigate
the world of modernizing
your applications, and
Porter, our little friend here
who will help you get
from point A to point B.
MARTIN OMANDER: Thanks, Wes.
I'm happy to be here.
What are these migrations,
and why should developers
be interested?
WESLEY CHUN: I'm glad
you asked, Martin.
Well, our job is to help
developers modernize
their apps, to take advantage
of new features and product
upgrades, to move to
a more modern release
of their development
language, and generally
keep their apps running
well to support theirs
or their customers' needs.
In each episode,
our friend Porter
here takes us on a short
excursion to the next Migration
Station.
Each ride attempts to
take the mystery out
of common migrations
that developers undergo
when modernizing their apps.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, I get it.
We're helping developers
take advantage of the latest
innovations from Google Cloud.
So which migrations are
we focusing on first, Wes?
WESLEY CHUN: I'm glad
you asked, Martin.
The first set of migrations
we're going to tackle
is for original Python
App Engine users.
Since its launch in 2008
as our first Cloud product,
we've continued to innovate
and open the platform,
as well as introduce
some new products.
MARTIN OMANDER: I'm familiar
with Cloud Functions and Cloud
Run.
Are you saying users
can run their App Engine
code on those platforms, too?
WESLEY CHUN: Yes, Martin.
App Engine users have options.
You can do nothing at all
and stay on App Engine,
you can modernize to the
next-generation App Engine
service, you can
break up larger apps
into micro-services
for Cloud Functions,
or you can containerize
your app for Cloud Run.
Using Docker is another
way to stay on Python 2
forever, for all of
you hard-core folks.
If you don't want to learn
about Docker or containers,
you can still containerize
using Buildpacks,
but only Python 3 is supported.
This series will
cover most of these,
but starts with helping you
move to unbundle services.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hmm.
I like that Google Cloud is
embracing openness and helping
make my apps more portable.
But what's wrong with having
the legacy App Engine services,
anyway?
WESLEY CHUN: Well,
nothing at all, Martin.
But while bundled
services are convenient,
App Engine isn't as
open as it can be.
For example, while webapp2 is
a great lightweight framework,
moving to something
more general,
like Flask, allows your
app to be more portable,
meaning you can run your
apps outside of App Engine
if desired.
By the way, if you
don't use Flask,
you can use any
WSGI-compliant framework
that does its own routing.
You can read more in
the documentation.
Also, many of App
Engine's original services
have matured to becoming
their own standalone Cloud
products, anyway,
and it's really where
all the new features are going.
So migrating lets users take
advantage of their continuing
innovation.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
I understand the
tech implications.
But before the main content,
what can you say about cost?
WESLEY CHUN: Yes,
it's true, Martin.
Migration does involve regular
usage, so analyze varying costs
you may incur, like
datastore access, pricing
of the new standalone Cloud
products, free-tier quotas,
and so on.
In other words, don't go into
it blindly and get surprised
afterwards.
For this reason, the tiny sample
app used for the migrations
should not incur any charges.
But don't let its datastore
usage go out of control.
MARTIN OMANDER: Watching
videos is great,
but I want to get
my hands dirty.
Where should I go, Wes?
WESLEY CHUN: All right, Martin.
Well, except for this
video, each migration module
has an associated code lab,
a self-paced, free online
tutorial to give
you that hands-on.
Users get both the
starting and ending code,
so you can reset
back to the beginning
or compare your
answers with ours.
While some migrations
are strongly recommended,
others are optional.
It really depends on what
makes sense for your app.
If you need to start
migrating today,
several code labs have
already been published.
So there really is
no reason to wait.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hey, Wes.
You mentioned you'll give
us a sample app to migrate.
Can you walk me through
that starting sample
so I can get an idea
of what to expect?
WESLEY CHUN: Sure.
I'm happy to, Martin.
It's a simple Python
2 guestbook app
using the webapp2 framework.
It records each page visit as
a datastore entity with the App
Engine ndb client library.
We're going to
dive into the code,
but let's pause so
you can clone the repo
or download the zip file.
OK.
Jump to the module 0 code,
and let's go to the computer
to walk through it now.
Let's start with the
application file main.py.
The key imports bring in
the webapp work framework,
plus its templating system,
and the App Engine ndb
library to access datastore.
Next is a data model.
For each web page visit, we'll
autosave the timestamp as well
as some visitor information,
and that's it-- fairly basic.
store_visit creates the
entity with the visitor
info we want to save, such
as IP address and browser
type or user agent,
then writes it
with a timestamp to datastore.
Yes, I know,
X-Forwarded-For should
be checked first, and so on.
But this is just
a sample app, so
grabbing the first thing
that looks like an IP address
rather than being
thorough and correct.
fetch_visits queries for
the most recent visits,
which will be displayed
with the HTML template.
For the primary
handler, the app only
supports HTTP GET,
which is why it's
the only implemented method.
It registers the visit, queries
for the 10 most recent visits
to display, including
the one just recorded,
and then passes the data
to the template to render.
Finally, we have a routing
table at the bottom.
I think all "Hello
World" app.yaml's look
like this-- am I right?
It's a python27 app where all
routes go to app in main.py.
The last file is a
basic index template,
with some header info, then
a "for" loop that displays
the most recent visits.
OK.
That's a quick walk-through
of the baseline sample
app you can find in the
module 0 repo folder.
MARTIN OMANDER: Thanks for the
tour of the sample app, Wes.
Now I know what
we're starting with--
a basic Python 2 app using the
bundled App Engine services.
By the way, is this series
for all App Engine users?
WESLEY CHUN: Glad
you asked, Martin.
Nope, it's not for everyone.
If you're a Python 3, Java 11,
PHP 7, or Go 1.12 or newer App
Engine user, you're already on
the next-generation service.
This first set of
migration modules
is only for developers,
consultants,
IT decision-makers,
integration specialists,
or any technical professional
interested in bridging
the gap between the first- and
second-generation App Engine
runtimes.
MARTIN OMANDER: Thanks
for helping users
with these
modernization resources.
Do you have any roadmap on
which videos we'll see first?
WESLEY CHUN: Well,
thanks, Martin.
As mentioned earlier, a
starting set of code labs
is already available, so we'll
be producing videos for them
first.
But if you're curious,
here's a list of all the code
labs you can try now.
There's no need to
wait for a video
if you need to
get started today.
MARTIN OMANDER: Thanks
for the heads-up
of what content to expect.
Are there any other resources
that we can share today?
WESLEY CHUN: Oh,
definitely, Martin.
In addition to the
migration modules,
here are some links to the
documentation describing
our long-term support
of these older runtimes.
And more importantly,
that page links
to the migration guides for
each of the legacy runtimes.
Next is the repo for
the samples in the docs,
and finally, yet another
repo with migration samples
contributed by the community.
We look forward to
having you join us
for the first leg on
our migration journey,
as well as on other
serverless expeditions.
This is Wesley Chun on
behalf of Martin and Porter,
saying ciao for now, but we'll
see you at the next Serverless
Migration Station.
[MUSIC PLAYING]